so women uh education jobs uh we had
your friend Nick Fuentes on right um and
he was adamant women should not go to
college period they do not should not go
to college with the maybe the exception
of certain people that are going into
stem medicine law but he's basically an
advocate for that you went to college
but what do you think should should
women go to
college I mean it didn't really help me
with much I I played Sports so I really
enjoyed college sports um but no I mean
it's not it didn't help me in the
workforce it didn't really do much for
me I would say and I and I studied
economics I actually had a real degree
so so I guess my the the the
conversation I'm looking for is college
overall has become watered down it's
become uh sort of pointless to many
extent uh College uh debt is out of
control it doesn't offer as much value
it used to to offer you're not
necessarily unique if you go to a
four-year University and you graduate
hey I'm College you're not guaranteed a
job but should women specifically not go
to college I would say most women
shouldn't you know what women would what
women would you suggest to
go I engineering is probably a good
degree you know I don't think most women
want to do it but this is the stem field
that I was talking about science
technology Eng you know got it um what
about work should women go back to the
pre-1950s and just stay at home cook
clean Mother raise the kids not go to uh
it's so it's so interesting when you
look at history and you like it's
actually like hilarious I think it's so
funny when I hear these chicks talk
about oh I missed the days when we just
got to stay home and not work it's like
what do you think the 1800s were
like what do you do you think your life
was easier when you were working on a
farm um so you know I I think that women
should listen to their husbands you know
I I know women that do work and they
work for their husbands I I think it
depends on every family's financial
situation I think I think it's better if
the women can stay home not every family
can afford to do that you know but well
look I can kind of agree with you on the
whole listening the husband thing but
that's not the point what happens before
they have a husband though like I mean
you have to eat like so what should they
do for money if they don't work or go to
college or anything like that like walk
me through the logic like yeah college
is useless don't do it but you still
need a work but maybe you're 22 years
old not ready to get married is she
smart or stupid well what are most women
well um okay well if I was going to tell
like a 22-year-old I mean I would get a
job where where you would want to meet
your husband that's what I would say so
if you want to date a doctor you know
you work as an assistant at like a
medical clinic so you should go to I
mean I would say should I would say it
really depends on the person so I'm not
really into like Broad advice but no but
this is important because I have a a lot
of conversations with women about this
because I actually have a very unique
perspective of this Pearl because you
know in my old age of 40 plus 42 uh I
see women that have focused on their
career so much right and have done all
the high body count travel living it up
beautiful women who are now 38 40 42 44
still single and my advice to them is
yeah you probably should have
prioritized a man marriage if that's
what you want which many women do right
um but at the same time I also give that
advice to a 22-year-old and what's their
what's their first thing they say I
don't want to get married right now I
want to live my life I want to do these
things so how do you give this knowledge
to a young 22-year-old girl who's like
what are you telling my mom told me I
should not rely on a man I need to make
my own money I need to get a degree I
don't care what you say pearl I'm
listening to my mom I'm not trying to
get married at 22 years old like if you
were having that conversation what you
do with plenty of women how would you
basically get on their level to
basically see what you're saying oh I
don't I say if you want to do that go do
it have fun okay like I'm not yeah do
you warn them of what the future would
look like well yeah I mean I can go
through the anti-depressant stats like
the women over the age of 45 that are on
anti-depressants um you can go through
the single childless women statistics
but you know I I'm not in the business
of forcing people to live one way or
another you know you know I can't
speaking more gener I can't really like
put a gun to her head well let's let's
have some fun let's put a gun okay to
Natalia's head Natalia is 26 years old
okay she's an attractive girl okay um
you guys are similar age she went to
college uh she comes from a good family
um she works she works at Value
attainment she's moving up uh for
someone like her
specifically you know if you could if if
Dr Pearl put on her medical hat what
would you tell what would you tell Nat
well what what outcome do you
want um this is a place that I'm going
to find my career and I probably will
meet somebody along the way and I
probably have met someone so but yeah oh
okay she seems yeah she's good that's it
that's how this works that just that
Whispers an answer and you agree with it
yeah sure that that did not sound
convincing by either of you right now
now the men are fighting with the women
so now what are you solving for I mean
longterm this is a company that I want
to build you know it's a company of
opportunity um and I know along the way
there'll be a lot of people I will meet
and I will probably find who I'm looking
for along the way so I am working for so
I think this is important because you
you you know in in you know some people
say you know this is an advice but it
kind of is but it's you know kind of I
don't know but at the end of the day
we're all kind of giving opinions which
could be perceived advice if you met a
guy that you really liked would you
prioritize that um yeah that would be
have to be my priority that's going to
be my next chapter in my personal life
so that's an area that I do have to give
time and attention okay so knowing
female nature you're a woman you know
you know female nature what age do you
think most women even start thinking
about actually settling down having kids
getting married all that stuff I would
say after 25 in modern day yeah I think
that's fair I think that's fair I see a
lot of women they get the 30 it and then
oh my God so but prior to 25 mhm you
know how are they eating how are they
living how are they making money oh what
I would say I would just say be a virgin
young chica be a virgin and get married
that's what I would say I would say
that's the best option if we want to
look at you know if your goal is family
and children that is the best option for
you gotcha so how would you suggest a
woman would court or how would you
suggest a woman get experience I'm not
saying sleeping around cuz I'm not
condoning sleeping around but how would
you suggest a woman like that you know
she's been home like to be able to
identify this is a man that is going to
oh God women can't identify we're
terrible at it so then that's my point
what suggestion would you have to those
women that stay I think like
traditionally it used to be that the
dads would help you and so the dads
would say these are like Five Guys in
town I think this would be the ideal all
right so you got a you got a daughter
right let's just say and you say these
five guys they're they're everything
that I think would be good in a husband
daughter pick one boom there you go so
kind of like the Indian culture or they
kind of they give the marriage yeah they
do that in Indian culture too so um I do
want to talk about women and the body
positiv we touched on some of the stuff
looks marriage you just brought up
virgins okay this is something that I
find fascinating this conversation about
Virgin Brides right I I one of my
favorite movies of all time is The
Princess Bride um and this whole concept
of virginity and look you know in high
school and college maybe I took one or
two right but at this phas in my life
the last thing I'm looking for for me is
a virgin cuz I'm a little bit older
right but I understand that concept so
would you consider yourself a
traditional guy um in many respects yes
but maybe not uh in certain categories
are you like looking to get married the
next couple years I'm looking to have
kids and a and a girl for sure okay but
traditional marriage as far as the
government getting involved in my life
you I don't know if you know I was
married married oh my God I had no idea
so you go well at the end you're going
to flip it on me have this conversation
but yeah I do I would like I I would say
that how about this I've been pretty
traditional but I'm becoming more
traditional evolving as we kind of
discussed uh would you say you're
traditional no you're not no I wish I
was but no
how so well when I I think of like a
traditional woman I think of a woman
that like I don't know I was an athlete
growing up okay so I was like I I was I
spent like four hours a day in the gym I
I don't think that's like a traditional
all right so you played Sports I don't
think that's I mean in modern society a
lot of girls play sports how else are
you not traditional but you would love
to be traditional well that's that's the
main thing just you're an athlet well I
think traditional women get married
before the age of 25 so okay so um but
The Virginity thing yeah I think yeah I
also think that that's part of it
traditional women they're virgins they
wait till they're married they they're
typically
like ra like they're more raised um like
I I just don't see athletes like female
Athletics as being like the epitome of
traditionalism and you've already
answered this you're you said you're not
a
virgin not a GU okay no I mean it's not
like breaking news okay you're not
married this is not breaking news I get
it you've said you're not traditional
but you wish you were but you're also
saying hey women go be traditional
you're also like look I'm not really
traditional but this is what I would
recommend for you right but when it
comes to virginity thing it's actually
pretty fascinating to me because I have
some stats Malik pulled that up in a
second you said the ideal marriage of
two virgins is getting married and
staying married for a lifetime is good
you've said that right non- virgin women
cause all of the world's problems
interesting okay so you know in the west
specifically the concept of Virgin
Brides in my opinion is so farfetched
today yeah 4% I think it's like three or
4% yeah so um I want to pull up these
stats um how can we go back in time and
re recreate this traditional virgin
lifestyle and and like how much does
this actually weigh on your mind that oh
I'm not a virgin I wish I was like I
don't know why could done a lot more
since every show I go on they bring it
up right well why do we bring it up bro
cuz you talk about it it's like I think
about this but here before you answer
look at these stats look at these stats
real quick so punch in a little bit so
in the 197 all you have to do is look at
the um top number okay so in the 1970s
this is when you get married uh 21% of
women were virgins okay by 1980s it was
17 1990s it's 14 2000s it's 12 by 2010s
specifically when social media hits the
scene it plummets down to 5% you said
now it's closer to 3% so is this can we
put the toothpaste back in the tube or
are we doomed you know what's crazy if
you look up 1920 the first sexual
Revolution was actually in the 20s wom
suffrage everything that goes and so it
was actually like 85% in the early 1900s
so think about how far that's fallen in
100 years no we are in full agreement
with this we are in full agreement I'm
not like these are these are stats not
this is not zero opinion but you know
the concept of Virgin bride are we just
too far gone that it's like we're not
these numbers are trending that way how
do you envision it going from 3% back to
five back to 10 back to 20 it won't it
just won't it won't no I I don't see it
going back unfortunately if you can kind
of put things in place to make it go
back in place what things would you put
in place to influence more of that ch I
me well I I I would say women respond
very quickly to social shame um when
when when something is socially shamed
as a
society um that is typically when you
see women make changes um for example
and I don't know you you guys have to
see this on the show you just hear women
repeat back the same things that they've
heard like on in the media I've heard
about Kim Kardashian getting married so
many like so really I I think the only
way to swing it back is the culture and
through social shame but I don't really
see that happening so yeah I I don't
know no but that's that's my point so
when you guys ask me you're like well
what would you tell a 22-year-old chick
it's like well I can give them this
advice but I'm not stupid like I know
the culture you know I mean give but I
don't know like if you had a daughter
like what are you going to tell them
it's better to have multiple partners or
zero Partners or like one partner for
life I mean Adam knows where I stand I
say be a virgin yeah exactly that's just
me but it just the reason also why is
because to me it's like you can't handle
a level of discipline and you can't
handle a level of like keeping something
that's private private you know like
being able to be tempted with something
like that I think that's a level of
discipline that's very hard for people
to have so you value it and so for me
I'm I'm with I'm not like going to argue
like go sleep around cuz that's not what
I pr well I know chicks that have done
it like I I genuinely know chicks that
haveit done that have waited till they
were married I I know a couple like one
no I know I can think of three off the
top of my head I could probably think of
more that's the 3% yeah yeah yeah not
many it's rare it's totally R but when I
look at their outcomes for life I'm like
well like they're probably the happiest
married people I know like under the age
of 40 cuz there are stats that show that
the less body count you have uh the
longer marriage lasts it's just again
very farfetched in society what do you
think about the girls we've had this on
the show a bunch of times who are born
again virgins would you ever consider
yourself a born again virgin or you are
you living in reality I'm going to start
saying that on the shows I swear to God
no no no um no I I don't think you can
re become a virgin I don't know why they
say that yeah I ask that all the time
like yeah I'm a virgin now like really
how does that work yeah I mean I think
those chicks you're going to kind of
have a hard time selling a guy on that
like yeah they got it for free but you
sir need to marry me first or they're
practicing absence now I mean you you
might get a taker I just think that's a
hard cell so but you also talked about
the social shame you got to shame them
into agreeing but well I think we could
start by not rewarding it I think that's
step one maybe no money no only fans uh
maybe the guys come in stop marrying the
Kim Kardashian stop giving these women
commitment neon you know men used to
like shame other Sims you know Dylan
danis is really doing a service to the
men and the men throughout this country
but you know it's interesting because
you talk about the free markets and
capitalism I would say the onus is on
the men the simps the guys who are
paying these women because if guys
stopped paying the only fans and the sex
workers and the strippers what have you
then they would stop doing it but
there's a major market for that so they
keep do it so at what level does the men
have accountability for rewarding you
have the same energy for drug dealers do
I have the same energy for drug de so if
a guy deals drugs is it the crack
addict's fault or is the drug dealer's
fault I I think addiction is a lot
different for being addicted to drugs
than being like yeah I just want to see
some ass why do why do we have why no
why do we have empathy for drug
addiction but not sex addic addiction
you know there are studies that say that
sex is a need for men so when you have
one out of three men that either virgins
are having had sex in the past year it's
like it's on the internet they're going
to go somewhere now I I don't believe in
porn if this is Pearl's world I would
just ban it all I would just be like
that's banned that's band but it's
interesting how when women make a poor
decision we find a way to blame it on
the men but when men blame make a poor
decision we blame it on we blame it on
them so um interesting analogy with the
drug dealers but at the end of the day
it comes with choice but like you said
you would ban it there Banning is a
slippery slope you know this on your
social media accounts you know this that
you don't want to be banned so why can
you ban speech but not ban activities or
ban what people want to do we we saw
what happened with prohibition tried to
ban it it was Reckless okay you try to
ban um people making decisions with
their own bodily autonomy people will
react to it how could you ban something
that the market wants how would that
work well I mean people are still going
to do it illegally of course but I don't
really want to live in a world like
Amsterdam where you can go down the
street and get a hooker and that's
really like you know have you seen that
where the women are like in the front
I've been to the red light yeah and and
so it's like do you really want to be in
a society that is so accepting that we
accept that I I would argue no I don't
think the argument should be well
someone's going to buy it we should just
make it legal I don't really but there's
levels to that and I you you have a
point I get it because you know there
there is some ability there but you're
also saying that there's some sort of
equivalency to uh a crackhead to a dude
who wants to go to a strip club I would
say that there's Nuance to this there
are sex addicts there are porn addicts
and there's some guys that just kind of
want to have a fun night on a Saturday
night just like with drugs there's crack
addicts and some guys that want to Smoke
Joint I'll tell you what we could make
an equivalency to the the one out of
three very very lonely men in this
country a lot of these men still do jobs
that run the infrastructure in society I
mean you heard Andrew Tate talk about
when he did the cam business um men
would send their life savings yeah you
don't think that's a a form of addiction
a form of loneliness like we can't have
empathy for that yeah but whose fault is
that and it it everyone's choices in
life is their own fault but my point is
when we were talking about the sex
workers you immediately blame the
customers and whenever women make a bad
decision we have a tendency to blame the
men that was my point I'm not even
blaming I'm just saying that it's a free
market so as example those onethird of
men we've seen that stat onethird of men
are virgins I ask myself well why are
they virgins all right maybe they're
young maybe they have no game maybe they
don't have any respect from women cuz
they don't deserve respect they're broke
they're fat they're sloppy they're
losers they play video games they have
no game they have no skill set you know
what homie Hector maybe you should be a
virgin until you improve your life so
but that's a small percentage of men
that's like if you break down the
numbers that's not the majority I mean
overweight sure but everyone's fat you
know that's not like a men or women
thing but
but again but again you feel bad for
those guys I who I feel bad for is the i
i there's two groups of men that I have
a lot of empathy for one is the average
men that do not get respect in this
country again 45% of men almost one out
of two men do a job that makes the
country run and a lot of times
especially in the influencer space I I
see this a ton where we on the
average men that make this country run
none of us could do what we do without
them the second empath the SE the second
group of men that I have a lot of
empathy for are the traditional men that
do the right thing and get married and
they typically have average jobs work
the same job for 20 years and then come
home one day to a woman that has taken
half of their assets and I've been on
the other side of that and I've
interviewed these guys I have a ton of
empathy for them because they have no
idea what they are signing up for yeah
no men definitely need to be forewarned
of sort of the uh pitfalls of marriage
but I'll say this I'm almost taking like
a different angle to you but I am a man
I I I consult with men I coach men I I
I'm one of those dudes that actually
want men and women to win I'm not that
person that's like men win lose women
win men lose no I think we can all win
on hear me out those men from a macro
standpoint from an economic standpoint
you're absolutely right the the millions
of truck drivers okay the millions of
guys that work with their hands the
millions of plumbers from a macro
standpoint you're absolutely right but
from a micro standpoint are you
basically saying that I have to respect
Carl the truck driver just because he
drives a truck what else is he doing
with his life is he a good person is he
is he contributing to society is he
raising his kids is he actually active
in his community is he uh practicing
philanthropy but it's just because he
drives a truck I don't think he deserves
respect I think from a macro standpoint
I respect what the men do but I don't
think I already to respect Carl cuz he
drives eight hours in a truck every day
so it's very new I think it's like a
pretty privileged position to be in
honestly because he like the average men
allow you to do what you do and live how
you live so I I think you should treat
the people that help you get to where
you are with a lot of respect yes okay
simply for having those jobs just cuz
they have a job they deserve respect I I
think that you should respect the I'll
give you an example Uber drivers I
couldn't get anywhere without my Uber
drivers now it's it's a normal job right
it doesn't you know it's not like a
necessarily hard job to do but yes I
think the average men in this country
that work normal 9to FS deserve respect
so you know Elon mus has a quote that
you are paid in the proportion to the
problem that you solve you get paid by
delivering value so as an example I work
now I'm not doing this in the financial
markets okay I'm a financial wholesaler
for a very Niche product and I'm my
company myself are the best in the world
at this one thing called Life
Settlements we are the best of the best
of the best and we are highly
compensated for it that's how I made my
money that's how I met pbd in the
financial world but very few people can
do it and that's why we're paid a lot
but anybody mhm can drive Uber Uber
anyone can clean a studio be a janitor
so the lower level of a job the less
problems you're solving the less you'll
be paid so you know how many YouTubers
are out there okay there's tens of
millions how many YouTubers have more
than 10000 ,000 Subs 2% how many have
more than a million Subs like Pearl less
than 1% so it'd be like saying just
because you're a YouTuber you deserve
respect it's like no respect is earned
not given it's you need to establish
some credibility and competence in order
to get that respect so if you own the
trucking company it's like all right
that guy built the company and hired all
the guys respect but the guy on his
first day of a job just cuz dck I'm not
like oh my god do you do you not respect
the employees that work for you unless
they work their way up and own the
company I respect the hell out of them
that's the point like like I I think
that you should respect the people that
allow you to do what you do and so so
you have it here and I'm also talking
about in society as well so you know the
Uber drivers allow you to get from point
A to point B I yes I think they deserve
we're we're saying the same thing these
guys are SEC we just have a different so
you ever given an Uber driver a festar
yeah all the time right yeah you ever
given an Uber driver a one star no never
no how about a two star never how about
a four star I always just click five
okay so I'll tell you how often do you
Uber all the time I Uber everywhere I
don't even have a car I haven't a car in
10 years BR perfect let me tell you
something nine out of 10 trips they're
getting a five star you picked me up you
were there on time you took me to where
I was going cool awesome great job
respect but every one in 10 trips
someone's getting a three star someone's
getting a one star why
their car smelled they took the wrong
route they were rude that there's a
million different reasons but the point
is I'll respect you if you do a good job
and do the job you're supposed to do
five star homie all right great job
Pedro but but if you don't do a good job
sorry Rick you just got one star so the
whole like I'm just going to respect you
cuz you're an Uber driver that at what
point does Merit and value come into the
equation see now you're kind of
switching it you're like adding
something in where you're like well what
about the ones that don't do a good job
no and yes we know there are exceptions
Adam you never given but my point well I
mean I probably would but I I just I'm
pretty easy to please it's like you get
me to point A to point B I'm I'm happy
okay but my my point is that average men
that allow us to do what we do deserve
respect and too many times I see people
become successful and get to a certain
point and they don't respect the average
men that run this country not
everybody's going to own businesses not
everybody's going to become a top five
10% earner and quite frankly we couldn't
have the like the the country would not
function if everybody did 100% agree
with you on the infrastructure men do
not get the respect they deserve in that
regard on a macro level okay on a micro
level I think that you have personal
responsibility individual decisions let
me ask you this one thing um why do you
think that is meaning this is my
hypothesis prior
to um the 1980s 1950s however far you
want to go women weren't necessarily in
the workforce right they were relying on
a man so you could be in a small town in
De Moine Iowa or Jacksonville Florida or
you know uh wherever in C point is you
could get uh as an average man you can
get a normal girl she respects you cuz
she's not working she relies on you you
pay the bills uh an average income could
support a family of two normal guy
normal girl marriage family boom but as
women have been empowered gone to school
made more money now they developed a I
don't really need that $40,000 dude I
make 80 grand I'm only going to go out
with a guy that makes more than me you
you know about the hypergamy concept so
is it because women have made more money
they don't necessarily need that man as
a provider and is that the biggest
reason that they don't get the respect
from the women what do you think I would
argue women steal men's money actually I
would say they do it through child
support alimony and government benefits
more than anything but that's after they
get married in order to get married a
guy has to fall in love and make that
decision you don't need to get you just
need to track gu need like the wrong get
the wrong woman pregnant they say that
um but but women used to it used to be
everything was more family oriented
before so women would work they would
just work like it if a guy had a farm
the woman would work on the farm so they
would just be working together typically